I am not done one of these in a while I
feel rusty but feel good kind of like
that uh you know when you think of
something dirty and then you rent a
shower so you could really mess hey
what's going on you bunch of degenerates
now if you're a longtime viewer of this
channel you already know you're a piece
of [ __ ] with it with the great heart
have a piece of [ __ ] - and with shits
mingled together you get a porta potty
alright what the [ __ ] am i saying today
was very interesting uh today was my
very first day back at the gym now of
course I'm not doing it by myself this
time I do have a support group you may
have heard of him as uh now you guys
know a couple years back I did something
called funny fat fit which is really
good for me the first year - a year and
a half or so I lost about forty some odd
pounds or something like that I felt
good my titties were nice and tight I
can see the tip of my dick then of
course the holidays came around
Christmas Thanksgiving then I started to
eat and for some reason every time I
opened my mouth food would just you know
fly in it and I would never know how the
food would get to my mouth either cuz I
didn't put it there I need to
investigate that [ __ ] doo doo doo doo
but at the end of the day because I fell
off track so hard I gained back about 20
of the 47 pounds that I lost you know
I'm not gonna lie because I was a bit
disappointed in myself and you know I
understand that I'm still further than I
was before but it took a lot of sweat
tears you know and you know little
Dookie coming out the butthole so you
kind of just put it to the back your
mind and your friends tell you hey man
you still lost 20-something pounds so
you're still ahead of the game but at
the same time it's not where I wanted to
be so I was kind of just you know but
now that today is my first day back in
the gym it kind of reminded me of a
conversation that I had with somebody
about a week before when I was telling
this person that I was going to get fit
again now this dead person will just
call him dumbass now when I was talking
to this said fool he was giving me a bit
of advice that a lot of people give
others when it comes to weight loss
losing weight is not that hard you just
gotta put your [ __ ] mind to it bro
huh
and you got to understand when people
say this to you they're coming from a
great place but I gotta tell you this
that I wanted to slam you into a bag of
broken dreams it's not that hard you
just have to try hard that's the best
advice you could give somebody who had a
20-year love affair with bacon and once
again I enjoy these positive words but
it's more than just trying hard and you
should be able to do it you don't think
when people have tried to lose weight
their whole life
that they weren't trying hard are you
gonna be there everyday next to me in
the gym when my arms are so sore I'm
trying to flip you the [ __ ] off but I
can't cuz I can't move it if you've
never struggled with your weight or had
a love affair with food you don't know
what the [ __ ] were going to I eat bacon
like there's a cure to cancer side of it
please I think it sucks because people
have to stop giving others [ __ ]
answers for their weight loss issues a
lot of programs do that too and I fail
to understand why they do that you got
to let people know what they're going to
expect it's got a [ __ ] heart it's
like all my friends that tell me hey man
when you get to the gym that's already
half the battle no it's not put my mind
to a [ __ ] I've been putting my mind to
it but every time I close my [ __ ]
eyes
why the [ __ ] this keep popping up in my
head you don't know what I go through
you have a dream that you [ __ ] a
donut before but me neither that's crazy
now if you're trying to lose weight
here's some legit advice from somebody
who was 280 pounds it will suck so much
ass at first and it might be a few
months until you feel like you've broken
the habit because right now everything
that you're doing everything that I'm
doing is a habit it is ingrained in us
to stuff our face eat unhealthy foods
and have these bad habits it's not going
to be either you will wake up every day
for the first month
questioning life itself you have any
idea how many mornings after the gym I
pray to God to give me strength and when
he wouldn't answer I said Buddha what
about you [ __ ]
hmm it will be difficult and if you're
like me that has been fat for a majority
of your life it's going to be especially
hard for you people will and have been
telling you all kinds of stupid [ __ ]
visualize yourself skinny won't you
visualize the other side of my nutsack
[ __ ] all I know for me is that
it's been about two years since I
started funny fat fit and now I am but
20 I don't know like 25 26 odd pounds
down from where I was before so I'm
still ahead of the game but at the same
time I'm not where I want to be and so
I'm gonna be doing it again and you can
start with me too and if you do do this
with me which a lot of other people have
and they have gotten very far with their
fitness goals you are going to [ __ ]
with me cry with me be in pain with me
and we are going to curse out every
other skinny [ __ ] that walks
way asking us stupid questions like what
are you gonna need to do you if you
don't get the [ __ ] out my wack and to be
honest with you the reason why I'm
bringing back funny fat fit is because
it has been requested
highly I never thought that my journey
with my own health would have helped
this many people out but because you
guys have been asking so much it you
want me to suffer with you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I will do it again for you and
especially for me and this time we're
going to keep it off and we're gonna
change lives and remember my friends if
you don't see results quick don't worry
about it stick to it work on your
programming and figure out what's great
for you the only person that you are
comparing yourself to is the person that
you were the day before that's it you
know just for a quick heart to heart
moment one of the biggest reasons why
I'm even a comedian now has nothing to
do with notoriety fame people getting to
know me going up on stage and you know
having people cheer me on [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] it was just to make people laugh
and to make people's lives better so
this even though it's not really comedy
it still does that so if you guys need
this from me I'm here for you that's it
hey what is going on YouTube yes people
I just kind of I guess I like Lee said
that funny fast it is now back if you
guys want to see my workout progress and
what I'm doing you can follow me on
Instagram every time I'm at the gym
about to go workout doing something
healthy I will give you guys a bit of
something aspiring or something that I'm
struggling with or anything that has to
do with my fitness goal and I want you
to do the same now if you guys know
about funny fat fit and you had done it
before I've seen a [ __ ] ton of people in
their progress well guess what we're
gonna bring it back we're gonna bring it
back to Instagram so follow me at David
so comedy and hashtag funny fat fit just
to see your guys's progress and the
reason why we're hash tagging buddies
that fit and so that when people click
that they can see that they're a part of
a community that's also doing it with
them too not everybody has a homey
that's gonna work out with them and give
them motivation so what I need you guys
to do is hashtag funny fat fit when you
do something that's fit special I want
people to know that there are other
people doing it out there with them and
that they're not alone if they don't
have the support group so make sure you
guys do that I will see y'all next time
don't make a make sure you don't suck a
nut just Thanksgiving then lazy that
started to kick in and for some reason
every time I open my mouth fluid just
flew what the [ __ ] is flu it's a disease
you or a virus and you just have to try
hard
really dude why don't you shut the [ __ ]